Laurent Wauquiez et l'invité de Preuves
par 3 à quelques jours maintenant de
l'élection européenne bonsoir bonsoir
merci d'être avec nous pour ce
rendez-vous de Public Sénat avec
l'Agence France Presse et Dailymotion
vous incarnez d'une certaine manière le
clivage au sein de l'UMP avec votre
brûlot sur l'Europe il faut tout changer
mais cela dit vous contrairement à Henri
Guaino vous allez voter dimanche
UMP c'est bien cela oui oui pour une
raison pour une raison toute simple et
qui est sans équivoque c'est que le
meilleur choix possible pour ceux qui
veulent changer l'Europe aujourd'hui
c'est de voter
ce livre vous attire des commentaires
très durs à votre endroit au sein de
votre formation on verra ça tout à
l'heure avec Perrine Arnaud et puis avec
Raphaël hermano de l'Agence France
Presse nous verrons comment la vague
eurocritique pour écrire un séisme
politique en France dimanche vous direz
si vous pensez que le Front national
peut arriver ou non en tête dimanche
devenir donc le premier parti de France
comme l'indique et les sondages
aujourd'hui on a appris que Nicolas
Sarkozy donc s'exprimer dans une tribune
publiée par le point cette semaine sur
donc l'importance de l'élection de
dimanche l'élection du Parlement
européen est-ce que vous dites il est
temps où il était temps
non moi j'ai une approche qui est très
simple sur ce sujet la parole de
quelqu'un comme Nicolas Sarkozy qui a
toujours voulu changer l'Europe est
utile
il a jamais caché les dysfonctionnements
de l'Europe il a jamais cherché sur ce
sujet à mettre la poussière sous le
tapis et il a toujours plaidé pour des
évolutions profondes de l'Union
européenne et pour moi cette lucidité
est indispensable on a besoin de
politique qui au fond tout en gardant
une vision européenne sont capables de
dire qu'il faut faire changer l'Europe
et si cette lucidité se traduit
aujourd'hui par cette tribune on a dit
qu'il avait hésité cette dernière
semaine c'est qu'il y a le feu il y a le
feu à l'UMP divisé en plus fragilisé par
les affaires il y a le feu parce que le
Front national
profite de la désillusion européenne non
je pense juste que cette parole là un
débat est utile et une famille politique
ne doit jamais avoir peur du débat et au
fond un débat devient des divisions
quand il est pas assumé et l'UMP a tout
intérêt à assumer de pouvoir nourrir le
débat et la réflexion des Français sur
pour l'Europe oui il y a des
sensibilités différentes mais là Nicolas
Sarkozy arrive il va arbitrer tous les
débats justement non on croyez pas c'est
un débat et c'est un débat dans lequel
la parole de Nicolas Sarkozy ancien
président de la République a évidemment
de la valeur mais l'UMP a intérêt à
assumer le débat et à ne pas avoir peur
du démon et je suis parfois un peu
surpris là-dessus c'est à dire que au
contraire c'est quand une famille
politique est capable de montrer sa
diversité d'opinion qu'elle a de la
force surtout qu'au fond vous
m'interrogez en me disant est-ce que je
vais voter UMP évidemment que je vote
CMP pourquoi parce que l'UDI pour moi
est dans l'euro béatitude eux ils sont
pour un fédéralisme européen en se
cachant les yeux sur les limites du
fonctionnement de l'Europe le FN plaide
pour le repli national c'est pour moi
une erreur et ce qui fait la famille
commune de l'UMP sur le vote européen
c'est de dire au fond on a la fois une
vision européenne mais on est lucide sur
ce qui ne va pas dans l'Europe je le
répète ceux qui ont envie de faire
changer l'Europe pour eux le meilleur
vote possible c'est celui du M d'accord
mais néanmoins vous vous avez une vision
différent de Nicolas Sarkozy vous avez
été d'ailleurs le ministre des affaires
européennes par exemple sur l'axe
franco-allemand lui il le dit dans ses
conférences il faut absolument le
renforcer vous vous êtes contre-info
d'une certaine manière c'est moi je suis
à 300 % pour l'axe franco-allemand je
plaide pourquoi je pète pour le fait de
sortir d'une Europe à 28 dans lequel on
est trop dilué ça veut pas dire exclure
les autres pays ça veut dire faire deux
étages une Europe à 28 qui fonctionne
alors là vous êtes en totale
contradiction avec Nicolas Sarkozy pour
le coup pas du tout enfin c'est c'est
pardon mais qui plaide pour ça Edouard
Balladur avait plaidé pour cela au début
des années 90 Jacques Delors avait
plaidé pour cette idée de remettre un
moteur au coeur de l'Union européenne
Giscard d'Estaing qui s'est exprimé coup
sur coup dans le cadre de ces élections
européennes a dit le repas 28 ne marche
plus c'est exactement ce constat qui
fonde les idées que j'appuie dans le
livre c'est de dire on va garder
évidemment ce qui est aujourd'hui c'est
à dire ce marché économique à 28 mais il
faut remettre un moteur dans lequel on
met 6 pays on peut en faire plus si
nécessaire mais six pays cohérents qui
ont la même volonté de faire une Europe
avec les mêmes impôts un budget pour
faire des investissements une vraie
politique commune aujourd'hui c'est plus
le cas est-ce que Nicolas Sarkozy prend
un risque politique aujourd'hui en
signant cette tribune car on n'est pas
sûr que l'UMP soit en tête dimanche je
vous le disais je crois pas que Nicolas
Sarkozy il a l'habitude d'intervenir
pour ne rien dire et donc je ne doute
pas que ce sera une parole forte sur le
sujet européen et une parole forte de
changement et ça ça a du sens c'est pour
moi ce qui est important c'est que nous
comprenions et ça vaut pour notre
famille politique qu'on peut à la fois
être européen et en même temps dire
clairement qu'il faut faire changer les
choses en Europe on se souvient il y a
quelques semaines les sarkozymes avaient
porté au crédit de leur champion la
vague bleue des municipales on se
souvient de la tribune juste l'avant
veille du scrutin quand Nicolas Sarkozy
avait dénoncé les échos judiciaires il
avait parlé de la stasie aujourd'hui
est-ce que vous pensez que cette
nouvelle prise de position va peser sur
le scrutin
la tribune qui avait faite Nicolas
Sarkozy dans le Figaro était pas du tout
une tribune qui était liée aux
municipale non il était intervenu sur ce
qui était sa situation personnelle et
les écoutes les électeurs de l'UMP c'est
les sarkozymes bien sûr elle avait
clairement répondu aux attaques d'anti
faisait l'objet sur les écoutes
judiciaires j'étais mère j'étais engagé
dans la campagne municipale c'était pas
une tribune sur la campagne des
municipales et donc ça n'avait rien à
voir là qui est une parole dans votre
ancien président de la République sur
les questions européennes et encore une
fois pour moi ce qui compte c'est que
c'est la parole de quelqu'un qui a
toujours dit qu'il y avait des choses
qui ne marchait pas en Europe et qu'il
fallait être capable de faire changer
l'Europe c'est ça qui m'intéresse donc
vous retenez les critiques
essentiellement de l'ancien chef de
l'État constructive je retiens les deux
les deux et c'est pour moi les deux qui
comptent c'est d'avoir des gens qui sont
à la fois capables de dire oui il y a
des choses qui ne marchent plus et oui
on doit être capable de les faire
changer les deux on a entendu
Jean-François Copé et François Fillon a
appelé un nouveau vote sanction dimanche
contre François Hollande
l'ancien Premier ministre a parlé d'une
seconde raclée un carton rouge a dit le
président de l'UMP est-ce que vous avez
la même vision de ce rendez-vous
électoral non
j'ai pas la même vision pourquoi moi je
considère que quand on veut que les
électeurs votent on les appelle pas à
voter contre on les appelle à voter pour
je considère que quand on est dans
l'opposition on n'est pas juste là pour
s'opposer on est là pour proposer une
vision les élections européennes c'est
des élections importantes l'Europe c'est
plus un petit sujet ça nous affecte avec
les normes ça nous affecte sur l'emploi
ça peut créer ou non des conséquences
sur la gestion de la politique
d'immigration ça de lourdes conséquences
se contenter de dire on va voter aux
européennes pour mettre un carton rouge
à telle ou tel ça n'est pas mon approche
mon approche c'est de dire il y a un
projet qu'on propose je propose un
projet pour l'Europe ce propos un projet
de changement profond de l'Europe votez
pour ça votez et exprimez-vous sur cette
un peu comme sur la ligne d'Alain Juppé
en se prononce sur l'Europe dimanche et
pas pour ou contre le gouvernement je
vais vous dire c'est pour moi un
raisonnement qui est très important
je me méfie d'une tentation qu'on peut
avoir consistant à se dire comme les
socialistes échouent au fond on n'a rien
à faire attendant tranquillement qu'ils
échouent contentons-nous d'utiliser
l'exaspérations des Français et
transforme en ça en carburant électoral
c'est pas la bonne approche alors parce
que si on veut que les Français nous
fassent confiance et fassent confiance à
notre famille politique elle doit avoir
le courage de conviction forte elle doit
mettre des idées sur la table pour tout
changer
c'est-à-dire 30 ans de dérive et
d'aveuglement dans l'Union
ça va pas se faire sur un claquement de
doigts et le changement au niveau de
l'Europe ne va pas s'arrêter à cette
échéance électorale pourquoi parce que
pour moi le rebond de l'Europe ne se
fera pas uniquement sur cette élection
il suppose de se poser des questions
très fortes la première je l'ai évoqué
c'est comment est-ce que on peut sortir
de la dérive qu'à amené l'élargissement
d'une Europe à 28 c'est la première
question la deuxième question c'est
comment rééquilibrer une Europe qui est
trop présente sur les petites choses les
normes européennes qui exaspèrent tout
le monde trop absente sur les grands
enjeux par exemple
Erasmus qui ne concerne que 4% des
étudiants européens c'est quand même une
vraie défaillance politique qui date
d'il y a quasiment 20 ans et qui n'ont
qu'on n'a pas été capable de développer
à l'aune de ce qu'on pouvait en attendre
la troisième chose une politique
industrielle qui doit être plus tournée
vers un protectionnisme européen ah le
mode vous fait pas peur bien sûr que non
pourquoi est-ce qu'il ne ferait peur les
Chinois font du protectionnisme les
Japonais
la notion de protectionnisme lui il
réclame des accords de réciprocité
est-ce que les plastique peuvent arrêter
d'avoir peur des mots les accords de
réciprocité mais ça veut dire quoi ça
veut dire en clair qu'on fait du
protectionnisme ça veut dire que les
Chinois ça veut dire que les Chinois on
s'entend avec les autres pays la Chine
par exemple vous avez raison de faire du
politiquement correct c'est toujours
tellement mieux mais non altimum de dire
les choses ça veut dire quoi ça veut
dire que les Chinois ferment à 90 % leur
marché public et bien ça signifie que
nous aussi on doit avoir le droit de
fermer nos marchés publics et je n'ai
pas peur des mots ça suppose que quand
on en fasse de soi des pays qui ne
pratiquent pas totalement le
libre-échange on doit pouvoir faire du
protectionnisme européen c'est pas un
gros mot c'est pas un scandale de dire
qu'on va faire du protectionnisme
européen si les partenaires ne le font
pas il y a 20 ans on parlait de quoi
quand on parlait de l'Europe et
notamment de la politique agricole la
préférence communautaire et en assumait
de dire priorité aux produits agricoles
européens c'est pas un gros mot est-ce
que pour vous le traiter de
libre-échange qui est à nouveau négocier
depuis lundi entre l'Union européenne et
les États-Unis est un motif de peur
beaucoup de fantasmes certaines craintes
sans doute sont réelles votre avis mon
avis c'est qu'un traité de libre-échange
n'est pas en soi une bonne chose et que
donc ce qu'il faut regarder c'est qu'il
faut regarder ce qu'il apporte c'est
tout simple et par le passé on a trop
souvent signé des traités de
libre-échange pour signer des traités de
libre-échange l'exemple pour moi typique
et le traité qui a été signé avec la
Corée dans lequel on a accepté que la
Corée puisse exporter les produits de
ses chantiers navals alors même que ces
produits c'est ces bateaux sont
hautement subventionnés par l'État à
l'inverse nous l'Europe nous interdit
d'apporter des aides d'État nos
chantiers naval ça pour moi c'est
l'exemple d'un traité de libre-échange
dans lequel on a fait du désarmement
unilatéral donc ce traité je le
regarderai de façon très pragmatique moi
je refuse de considérer que par essence
un traité de libre-échange soit une
bonne chose s'il permet de rééquilibrer
oui mais il y a un cas très concret qui
me choque on apprend dans ce traité de
libre-échange des entreprises
américaines se verraient autoriser à
faire des recours contre des
gouvernements et contre des états
tribunal supradational exactement c'est
à dire au fond de la souveraineté
nationale pourrait se voir attaquer par
une entreprise privée là je le dis très
clairement c'est pas ma conception de la
vie publique l'Europe à la possibilité
de dire non évidemment dans les
négociations à deux petites questions
encore et c'est bien alors c'est très
bien ce que vous dites là c'est à dire
que l'Europe puisse de temps en temps
assumer de dire non voilà compte
considère pas comme une fatalité de
vouloir à tout prix signer un traité de
l'image vous votez dimanche mais j'ose à
peine imaginer que vous voterez pour le
candidat de votre partie pour la
Commission le Luxembourgeois yunker
c'est le diable le Luxembourg il devrait
même pas faire partie de l'Union paradis
fiscale pardon je vais très je vais être
très direct là-dessus je ne crois pas un
instant qu'on changera l'Union
européenne de fond en comble parce que à
l'arrivée on récupérera soit Schulz
soyons coeur arrêtons de faire semblant
les problèmes qu'aujourd'hui l'Europe
sont des problèmes beaucoup plus
fondamentaux et beaucoup plus structural
nominations quand même il y avait bien
des gens qui vont occuper les postes oui
bien sûr mais on vous le voit bien
aujourd'hui c'est pas juste une petite
affaire d'institution et c'est pas juste
une affaire de savoir quel visage vous
allez mettre à la tête de la commission
c'est une question beaucoup plus
fondamentale du fonctionnement de
l'Union européenne c'est votre réponse
sur yunker alors une réaction maintenant
à la volonté d'exprimer ou prêter à la
famille de léonarda de revenir en France
par l'espace Schengen puisque l'idée du
père semble-t-il ce serait de quitter le
Kosovo devenir croître et donc profiter
de l'espace Schengen alors tout de suite
Laurent Fabius a été très clair il a dit
c'est non il n'avait pas question ce
serait une fraude à la nationalité vous
êtes rassuré je ne suis pas du tout
rassuré parce que je trouve que
qu'est-ce que nous révèle cette affaire
ce que nous révèle cette affaire qui est
hautement symbolique c'est que la
politique européenne de l'immigration ne
marche pas et qui a d'immenses trous
dans cette capacité qu'on a perdu de
contrôler nos frontières le droit
européen ou le droit de Schengen permet
en réalité et on le voit avec cette
tentative de la famille leonarda fraude
de contourner les rares outils de
contrôle de l'immigration qu'on a au
plan national s'il passe par la Serbie
ce qui est apparemment une de leurs
tentative ils pourront effectivement
rentrer à l'intérieur de l'Union
européenne parce pourquoi parce qu'on a
bénéficié d'accord qui permettent
d'exonérer de visa et qui font l'objet
d'accord de partenariat entre la Serbie
et l'Union européenne qui ont été
négociées à la majorité qualifiée c'est
à dire que même sans l'accord de la
France de tels accords d'exonération de
visa ont pu être imposés donc pour moi
ça montre quelque chose de très simple
Schengen ne marche pas la politique
européenne de l'immigration ne marche
pas et il est important sur ce sujet
parce que c'est une politique qui ne
fonctionne pas que les États nationaux
puissent reprendre une partie de la
maîtrise de leur politique d'immigration
alors le FN 9 on dit tout à l'heure surf
sur le rejet européen au point
d'ailleurs qu'il pourrait dimanche
apparaître comme le premier parti de
France un séisme évidemment pour l'image
de la France pour François Hollande pour
le Parti socialiste mais aussi pour
l'UMP on en parle dans un instant
Laurent Wauquiez avec Raphaël hermano de
l'AFP après cet exercice crédible ou pas
vous nous le direz de politique fiction
signée Faustine Saint-Geniès
c'est une onde de chocs qui s'annonce et
Marine Le Pen ne cesse de le répéter le
Front national pourrait devenir le
premier parti de France une hypothèse de
plus en plus plausible si l'on en croit
les derniers sondages notamment grâce à
l'abstention c'est clairement
aujourd'hui un vote qui est installé
dans le paysage politique c'est
clairement un vote qui est un vote de
sanction mais également d'adhésion de la
part de l'électorat du Front national
c'est clairement également un vote qui
montre une plus grande pénétration dans
différentes classes sociales du Front
national qui ne se cantonne pas
uniquement aujourd'hui aux catégories
populaires l'irrésistible ascension du
FN dump sous pression une MP qui n'a pas
réussi à surfer sur sa victoire aux
municipales en raison de ses divisions
internes que ce soit monsieur Guéno que
ce soit leur invoquier c'est vrai que
ils expriment des avis qui sont sans
doute l'expression de la crispation et
et je dirais des inquiétudes et des
interrogations de nos concitoyens à
l'UMP sur ce sujet-là comme sur quelques
autres il faudrait effectivement qu'on
élève le débat et qu'on ait une ligne
directrice au lendemain du scrutin
dimanche prochain les différences entre
les tendances à l'UMP pourrait bien
s'exacerber d'autant que Jean-François
Copé le président du parti est affaibli
par plusieurs affaires ce qui pose
problème à l'UMP c'est le leadership il
n'y a pas de président légitime de l'UMP
à l'heure actuelle il faut élire un
nouveau président du MP dès que possible
et avoir un bureau qui fonctionne en
étant réparti sur le même modèle que
l'émotion le départ le fait de
départager d'émotions comme au PS
certains élus notamment dans le sud
pourraient être tent és de passer des
accords électoraux avec le FN en vue des
législatives de 2017 c'est d'ailleurs le
rêve de Marine Le Pen faire sauter les
dix qui restent entre les deux parties
son modèle l'italien John Franco finit
qui a des diabolisé le parti fasciste
dans les années 90 pour devenir
vice-président du Conseil du
gouvernement de Silvio Berlusconi
est avec nous là invoqué bonsoir Raphaël
notre concert de l'AFP vos questions
Laurent ok bonjour le FN en tête au soir
de dimanche vous y croyez
à ce stade j'ai pas envie de me
prononcer sur la question de savoir
est-ce que le FN sera devant ou non et
par contre une chose qui me surprend
c'est que certains semblent découvrir
que les Français ne sont pas satisfaits
de l'Europe et que ça se traduit et par
un risque de vote d'abstention très
important et par un risque de vote du FM
ce diagnostic-là c'est exactement en
ayant cette conscience très tôt qui a
deux mois j'ai voulu lancer ce débat sur
le sur l'Europe parce que je pense qu'il
faut qu'on arrête de faire semblant oui
les Français ont une forte
insatisfaction sur l'Union européenne
mais c'est une question qui est
importante de savoir si le FN arrivera
devant l'UMP ce serait la première fois
de une élection c'est important que le
FN serait premier symboliquement ça
aurait ce serait très fort si vous
répondre très franchement
personnellement je n'y crois pas
mais je ne crois pas que pour autant ça
doit aboutir de notre part au fait de
dire tiens si dimanche le FN n'est pas
en tête ça signifie qu'en fait on s'est
fait peur et qu'en réalité il y a pas de
sujet si il y a un sujet et ce sujet
existe que le FN soit en tête au premier
soit en tête aux européennes ou non ce
sujet c'est celui de l'insatisfaction
des Français par rapport à l'Europe et
notre réponse politique est la deux voix
possible la première c'est de laisser au
FN le soin de parler à cette
insatisfaction européenne et d'avoir
comme seul proposition celle du repli
national la deuxième qui est celle pour
laquelle je me bats et qui est cette
parole que je veux faire entendre sur
l'Union européenne qui est de dire oui
l'Union européenne nous a déçu sur un
certain nombre de sujets mais la réponse
n'est pas d'abandonner l'Europe la
réponse est de changer en profondeur
l'Europe et je crois que les Français ne
sont pas contre l'Europe ils sont contre
ce que l'Europe est devenue mais si on
est silencieux sur cette question si on
met le couvercle sur la marmite alors la
seule réponse sera l'abstention et le
vote du FN même si le FN n'est pas en
tête et qui fait mettons autour de 20%
il aura au moins déjà complet ce qu'il
avait fait en 2009 ce sera donc la
première fois et il y a pas il y a pas
quand même de quoi réfléchir aussi de la
part de l'UMP à savoir ce que ce qui n'a
pas été fait pour arriver à un tel
résultat c'est ce serait bien sûr c'est
à dire que enfin précisément le message
pour moi est assez simple
l'interprétation du scrutin des
européennes ne se résume pas à la
question de savoir si le FN est en
première place ou non si on aboutit
dimanche un score important du FN
conjuguer un score important de
l'abstentionnisme ça doit être une leçon
pour tout le monde et une leçon qui est
au fond qui consiste à dire quoi qui
consiste à dire que les politiques
doivent arrêter de faire semblant qu'on
doit arrêter de laisser ce débat aux
européennes phagocytés entre deux
postures soit celle de ceux qui seraient
pro-européens et qui au fond défendent
une espèce de fuite en avant avec sans
cesse plus d'Europe soit de l'autre côté
ceux qui sont contre l'Europe et qui
sont pour le repli national si on veut
répondre à au fond c'est inquiétude qui
est exprimée qu'on voit très bien dans
cette campagne des européennes et bien
on a besoin d'avoir un autre discours et
cet autre discours c'est celui d'une
lucidité sur l'Europe oui on peut avoir
une vision européenne et en même temps
avoir le courage de dénoncer ce qui ne
marche pas est-ce que le du score de
dimanche pourrait dépendre aussi
l'avenir des instances du parti on pense
de son président notamment Jean-François
Copé qui est affaibli ces derniers temps
et ce qu'on pourrait changer à
l'occasion de ce scrutin de président à
l'UMP j'aime pas trop moi cette façon de
faire de la politique pardon ou d'un on
met la tête de quelqu'un sur le bio en
fonction du résultat une élection le
sujet pour moi un sujet beaucoup plus
profond le sujet qui est plus profond
c'est quelle est la parole de l'UMP et
avec devoir la première c'est une UMP
qui au fond aurait peur de ses
convictions auraient peur de ses idées
et fera un filet d'eau tiède pour moi à
l'arrivée ça se traduit par une montée
très forte du vote FM le deuxième c'est
une UMP qui assume ses valeurs assume de
mettre des propositions fortes sur la
table ne se contente pas comme on le
disait tout à l'heure d'attendre l'échec
du PS mais propose elle une autre vision
c'est pour cette MP là que j'aime pas et
pour moi la question ne se résume pas
celle qui vous satisfait aujourd'hui si
je comprends bien non mais non
à votre question au sens où pour moi il
y a une phrase de Renzi qui résume assez
bien ça Renzi donc le premier ministre
italien dit la chose suivante je veux
faire changer mon parti pour faire
changer la France pour faire changer
l'Europe c'est exactement ça dont on a
besoin votre ligne et vous vous avez
vous avez envie de faire changer de
changer de partie donc peut-être aussi
de changer la tête du parti non ou des
fois de se résume jamais juste à une
question de casting ou de concours de
beauté je pense qu'on a un vrai débat
l'Inter de notre partie tant mieux
encore une fois j'ai pas peur des débats
un parti vie par son débat il est tué
par les querelles de personnes il vit
par le débat et et qu'on assume d'avoir
ce débat entre deux visions à
l'intérieur de notre famille politique
tant mieux moi je me bats contre une
famille politique qui ne dirait plus
rien ça je ne veux pas de ça pour ma
famille alors voilà pour le débat est-ce
qu'il faut changer également le parti en
matière de transparence
bon enfin on va pas tourner autour du
pot enfin les questions que vous posez
sont des questions qui sont notamment
liées aux affaires et aux révélations
qui a pu y avoir sur sur Big maillot
je connais pas les tenants et les
aboutissants de cette affaire mais il y
a deux choses en tout cas que je sais la
première c'est que ce climat d'affaires
à répétition est absolument délétère il
tue et a juste raison la confiance des
Français dans la politique et il faut
absolument arriver à casser ce cercle
des affaires politiques au financières
comment la deuxième c'est qu'il y a une
seule façon de le faire que ce soit
plaisant ou déplaisant que les
politiques l'aiment ou non la seule
réponse c'est une transparence absolue
et extrêmement exigeante et la seule
réponse sur cette affaire et je pense
que ce sujet là on l'ouvrira après les
européennes c'est effectivement une
transparence totale remise aujourd'hui
apparemment Jean-François Copé a promis
qu'il parlerait
apparemment tout de suite après les
élections c'est donc ce que vous appelez
de vos vœux qu'il apportera les
explications qui seront nécessaires la
semaine prochaine et je me suis déjà
exprimée là-dessus je n'ai pas changé
d'opinion vous savez que j'ai fait
partie des politiques qui ont voté la
loi sur la transparence
on n'était pas tant que ça pour moi
c'est un cap qui est très clair je n'ai
pas changé d'opinion surtout ces sujets
la seule réponse c'est la transparence
totale Jean-François Copé aurait pu être
ignorant des éventuels sur facturations
que Bygmalion dément par ailleurs j'ai
vraiment pas envie de rentrer dans ces
questions il a dit qu'il apporterait des
explications je pense que ces
explications elles viendront pour
l'instant c'est le temps de la campagne
européenne je souhaite que ce temps soit
conclu jusqu'à sa fin c'est-à-dire
dimanche ensuite la semaine prochaine
doit venir le temps des explications sur
les affaires Bygmalion c'est tout chaque
chose en son temps et je le dis
clairement pour moi la seule voie c'est
celle de la transparence est-ce que
cette affaire pourrait aussi être à
l'occasion de cette affaire on pourrait
aussi reparler de la campagne de Nicolas
Sarkozy parce qu'aujourd'hui
Jean-François Copé dit que lui-même ne
sait pas si à cette occasion il n'y a
pas pu y avoir un financement de la
campagne de Sarkozy en 2012 ça veut dire
que on peut on peut aussi reparler de ça
on met tout sur la table y compris les
le financement de la campagne Nicolas
Sarkozy entendu jusqu'à 10 Jean-François
Copé et maintenant je pense que comme
tout le monde ce qu'on attend c'est des
éléments d'explication il viendront en
temps et heure et en temps et heure
c'est la semaine prochaine on attend les
explications à transparence nous on
entend on attend les règlements de
comptes un peu non et vous avez vu je
l'ai clairement dit il s'éteint pour
personne qui m'est arrivé d'avoir des
différences importantes par rapport à
Jean-François Copé c'est un scoop pour
personne que il m'arrive d'avoir des
positions par rapport à celle que il
défend qui ne sont pas exactement les
mêmes en même temps je suis dans ma
famille politique et je n'aime pas un
mode qui consiste à l'intérieur de sa
famille politique à faire des règlements
de compte de personnes en utilisant ce
genre de choses moi j'ai des différences
et des débats d'idées de proposition
j'ai pas de règlement de compte
personnel on voit bien ce qui se joue
derrière c'est aussi la question du
leadership au sein de l'UMP il va y
avoir une élection en 2017 il devrait y
avoir une primaire en 2016 d'ailleurs
cette primaire vous l'appelez toujours
de vos vœux pour moi c'est indispensable
pourquoi parce que précisément elle
permettra de clarifier ce débat d'idées
à l'intérieur de notre permis politique
et que elle permettra de voir au fond
entre ces deux chemins une MP qui serait
plutôt sur une tendance timorée de
l'autre côté une UMP qui assume ses
idées de savoir ce qu'on choisit et ça
c'est le point important est-ce que
Nicolas Sarkozy aussi devrait s'inscrire
dans cette primaire ou est-ce que lui il
est au-dessus de ça apparemment il n'y
croit pas beaucoup pour lui-même pour
l'instant il sait pas exprimé il laisse
le soin de s'exprimer ou même est-ce que
vous envisagez d'être candidat moi en
tout cas ce que je ferais ce à quoi je
veillerai c'est que les idées auxquelles
je crois soient portées à la primaire ça
pour moi c'est essentiel et cette ligne
là je ne transigerai pas dessus si c'est
pas vous ça pourrait être un ticket avec
quelqu'un d'autre par exemple je fais
pas de la politique de de petites
compromis ou de petites casseroles en
revanche oui ces idées là je veux
qu'elles soient portées à l'occasion de
la primaire parce que je pense que sinon
ce à quoi ça conduira c'est une droite
qui revient au pouvoir pour ne rien
faire on a fait ça pendant 30 ans je
pense que ça suffit pendant 30 ans vous
avez fait ça je pense que pendant 30 ans
on n'a pas suffisamment réformé le pays
pour ne rien faire vous avez dit là
vous savez je me cache pas derrière mon
petit je vous adressez le reproche à
vous-même bien sûr et je l'ai moi-même
appliqué c'est à dire que enfin j'ai
essayé de faire mon propre travail
d'autodiagnostic je l'ai dit sans
ambiguïté
quand j'étais ministre de l'Emploi il y
a des choses où je considère que je ne
suis pas allé assez loin une fois mais
pas deux fois ça suffit tout à l'heure
on vous écoutant on a l'impression que
vous banalisiez un peu la parole de
Nicolas Sarkozy à propos de la tribune
qui va sortir dans le point vous disiez
oui la raison de s'exprimer il y a un
débats n'a pas porté le résultat en
réalité c'est une parole un peu comme
les autres est-ce que vous comme vous
avez Bertrand vous dit-il à droite
s'exprimer au même titre que Valéry
Giscard d'Estaing non pas du tout enfin
ce que ce que j'ai dit clairement et
c'est ça pour moi qui compte c'est la
parole de quelqu'un qui a toujours voulu
faire changer l'Europe c'est ça qui
compte et cette parole là pour moi elle
est importante elle n'est pas de même
nature que la tribune du Figaro la
tribune du Figaro c'était au fond la
tribune de quelqu'un qui était attaqué
au mépris je trouve d'un certain nombre
de règles de la démocratie et qui
s'exprimait c'était pas une tribune sur
les municipales là c'est une expression
apparemment qui est une expression sur
l'Europe et moi ce qui m'intéresse dans
la parole de Nicolas Sarkozy c'est celle
d'un homme qui a toujours voulu faire
changer l'Europe ça ça m'intéresse
on nous parlait des affaires il y a un
instant à faire est-ce que la politique
selon vous est malade de l'argent il y a
eu les révélations sur des associations
au Sénat il y a eu donc évidemment la
Ferrari des frais de communication et
puis il y a Isabelle barken Balkani qui
est en garde à vue dans une enquête
financière on sait pas si c'est un
rapport avec l'information judiciaire
qui était ouverte pour blanchiment de
votre fiscale qui la vise et d'ailleurs
et son mari monsieur Balkany vous avez
pu aussi citer les affaires de Aquilino
Morel conseiller de Hollande qui avait
ça 30 paires de chaussures qui faisait
cirer par un Chaouch dans les locaux de
l'Élysée on aurait pu aussi citer
l'affaire de Cahuzac moi je dirais juste
une chose très simple il y a une époque
c'était pas comme ça en politique il y a
une époque où la politique française
n'était pas comme ça il y a une époque
où vous aviez des gens monnaie qui avait
la réputation quand kiki en quantité
leur ministère des tendent eux-mêmes
l'électricité il y a une époque on avait
le général de Gaulle qui avait sur son
bureau de plumier un plumier qui était
payé par les services de l'Elysée parce
que il signait les cours de officiels
avec et impumier dans lequel il trompait
son encre et qui payait lui-même quand
c'était ses courriers privés cette
intégrité elle est plus que jamais
indispensable et surtout à une époque où
les politiques sont amenées à demander
des efforts à leur compatriotes donc oui
pour moi ça reste un marqueur très fort
je me souviens qu'on m'a souvent tapé
dessus sur ce sujet en disant la
transparence qu'est-ce que c'est que
tout ça etc si il y a besoin de
transparence dans la République Raphaël
n'accélération dans les affaires
judiciaires visant l'UMP ces derniers
jours on a parlé à l'instant de
l'affaire Isabelle Balkany l'affaire
Bygmalion est-ce que vous y voyez un
hasard ou
on va être simple bien sûr oui ça arrive
au moment des élections mais cette thèse
du complot a pas tellement d'intérêt ce
qui compte c'est que il puisse y avoir
la vérité qui soit établie je veux pas
qu'il y ait précipitation je veux pas
qu'il y ait de jugement hâtif je veux
pas qu'on parte à la va-vite n'importe
comment mais que les faits soient
établies c'est juste essentiel dans
toute démocratie digne de ce nom c'est
tout ni plus mais ni moins merci Raphaël
Perrine Tarnaud de Public Sénat arrive
maintenant juste après cette enquête de
Marie brémo sur l'hostilité à votre
endroit oui leur enfant qui est et la
montée en flèche on peut le dire au sein
de l'UMP après ce livre un brûlot et
Europe il faut tout changer Michel
Bernier d'ailleurs vous a lancé cette
mise en garde crier plus fort que Marine
Le Pen c'est dangereux voilà la réponse
par rapport à votre argument il faut
mettre les dossiers sur la table et
d'autres voix s'élèvent on le voit tout
de suite
il affirme que ce n'est pas un homme
pressé et pourtant à 39 ans Laurent
Wauquiez a déjà occupé plusieurs postes
ministériels mais en politique
visiblement les plus jeunes ne sont pas
forcément les plus optimistes je suis
plus confiant que lui dans les talents
de la France des jeunes français et je
n'ai pas peur du monde comme lui je ne
rêve pas de protectionner je n'arrive
pas de protection car moi je fais plus
confiance je lui ai dit l'autre jour je
pense que nous devons être plus
optimiste nous qui sommes peut-être plus
jeunes en politique en tout cas au sein
même de l'UMP donc ou de son mouvement
la droite sociale on aimerait percevoir
un peu plus d'enthousiasme de la part du
député-maire du Puy-en-Velay son
neurosepticisme passe mal surtout auprès
de son mentor en politique Jacques
barreau dans une tribune dénonçait des
idées maniquées et dangereuses
je pense que s'agissant son cas
il surf aujourd'hui sur une opinion un
peu désabusée qui sent l'Europe très
lointaine alors que l'Europe est tous
les jours beaucoup plus proche
populiste Laurent Wauquiez et si tout
cela n'était qu'une stratégie ils sont
plusieurs à le penser comme si susciter
la polémique était en quelque sorte une
nouvelle manière de faire de la
politique c'est le privilège de la
jeunesse c'est sans doute une dactique
d'émergence et d'ailleurs de ce point de
vue là il réussit la preuve c'est que
vous m'interrogez sur sur ces idées que
ce soit sur l'Europe le RSA ou encore la
transparence Laurent Wauquiez a souvent
fait entendre une voix différente y
compris dans son propre camp la vie
politique je la connais bien en France a
été jalonné de de
météorites qui sont qui ont illuminés
brièvement le ciel de leur parcours
singulier cette attitude qui le
singularise a également tendance à
l'isoler
investissement alors c'est intéressant à
l'UMP de faire parler les uns sur les
autres bonsoir Perrine ternaux vos
questions
ça c'est pas faux sur la tactique
d'émergence dont parle d'ailleurs Gérard
Languet votre stratégie finalement à
vous c'est qu'il y a moins de risques en
faire trop que pas assez
je vais être très simple ma stratégie
c'est d'abord d'assumer des convictions
sur l'assistanat j'ai entendu exactement
les mêmes discours que ce qui viennent
d'être tenus ou au moment où j'ai posé
cette question de l'équilibre en France
entre les revenus de l'assistanat et les
revenus du travail les mêmes
sont tous tombés dessus tous en disant
quelle horreur on n'a pas le droit de
dire ça les mêmes c'est-à-dire vos amis
vos amis du MP
ouais et puis au fur et à mesure ils ont
réfléchi ils ont regardé les faits et ce
sont aperçus que ce qu'on disait
renvoyait sûrement un vrai problème de
la France aujourd'hui si vous les
interrogez ils diront tous les positions
qu'à l'époque on avait eu le courage de
secouer je pense c'est pas tellement le
problème qui est à l'époque c'était les
termes que vous avez employés non et
l'autre et de ce point de vue qu'est-ce
qu'on a la France est malade de quoi
elle est malade d'une politique vieille
d'une politique poussiéreuse dans lequel
on a des gens qui n'ont plus le courage
de dire les choses qui se cache derrière
les mots et qui préfère fuir les
difficultés je refuse de faire ça je
pense que la politique française a
besoin un moment de s'interroger ça fait
30 ans qu'on est sur les mêmes discours
dans le reportage il dit que vous êtes
trop pessimiste il vous reproche
finalement de manquer un petit peu de
souffle de vision vous me permettez une
remarque Jean-Pierre Raffarin m'a
répondu quoi il m'a dit oui tu as raison
l'Europe à 28 ne marche pas mais on peut
pas arriver à la changer qui est
pessimiste
moi je crois au contraire qu'on peut la
changer moi je crois qu'il est toujours
possible de changer des erreurs je crois
repli c'est remettre un moteur enfin ça
veut dire
pas du tout c'est avoir le courage de
dire oui on a le repas 28 mais
remets-toi un moteur à l'intérieur c'est
extraordinairement optimiste quel
défaitisme de toute cette classe
politique qui considère que vous ne peut
plus rien changer que on est condamné à
raisonner de la même chose quand
Jean-Pierre Raffarin me dit oui c'était
une erreur de faire l'élargissement
aussi vite mais c'est trop tard c'est
optimiste c'est terrible comme constat
de défaillance moi je crois la
possibilité de changer les choses je
crois que la politique n'est jamais
inscrite dans le défaitisme je crois
qu'on peut inverser la donne je crois
qu'un pays comme la France peut un
nouveau serait inventé mais à une
condition une condition une condition de
ne pas être lâche mais de ne pas fuir
les difficultés et de ne pas fuir le
constat on a bien compris il y a des
choses en position sur l'Europe on en
parle depuis le début alors après
l'assistanat après l'Europe anglais ça
sera quoi alors vos prochains défis là
vous allez lancer à l'opinion on a posé
un problème qui était celui de la
transparence on l'a évoqué tout à
l'heure oui vous avez raison aussi quand
on est un certain nombre à dire que les
politiques doivent faire preuve de
transparence oui ça crée des tensions
vous avez dit je
veux absolument ça veut dire quoi une
transparence absolue vous avez pas
développé chien c'est quand vous posez
tout sur la table ça veut dire pour moi
mais très simple c'est que on contrôle
le patrimoine des élus au début de leur
mandat et à leur fin ça veut dire que
dans l'utilisation des comptes ça veut
dire que ça n'existe pas comme ça
n'existe pas est-ce que je peux par
exemple vous poser une question vous
savez à l'intérieur de l'Assemblée
nationale et du Sénat quels sont les
politiques qui ont des responsabilités
professionnelles à côté est-ce que vous
savez quand il vote s'ils sont ou non
conflit d'intérêt quand moi je suis dans
ma mairie s'il y a une conflit d'intérêt
la personne se déporte les
professionnels
par exemple vous savez vous connaissez
quelle est la profession par exemple de
me dire si un parlementaire qui a par
exemple une responsabilité d'avocat à
traiter avec telle ou telle entreprise
est-ce que vous êtes capable de me
donner cette réponse alors ça
effectivement il fallait après regarder
sur le cabinet d'avocats
c'est impossible aujourd'hui en France
c'est pas possible dans n'importe quelle
démocratie c'est possible
contrôle oui mais tout ça juste pourquoi
est-ce qu'on parle de ça on parle de ça
tout simplement pour dire quoi c'est que
au fond si jamais vous ne voulez rien
dire et si vous restez bien dans le
filet de la pensée unique il y a pas de
problème tout va bien mais avec des amis
et vous faites de la politique pour ne
rien faire je ne veux plus faire de la
politique pour ne rien faire c'est la
bonne stratégie c'est pas ça c'est que
dans un pays qui est malade dans un pays
qui va mal
transgression
j'ai pas de souci mais le sujet c'est un
sujet qui est beaucoup plus profond la
question de la stratégie politique qui
est décryptée par toute cette génération
qui visiblement a beaucoup fait de
stratégie politique moi mon analyse
c'est que le pays va pas bien et qu'un
pays qui va pas bien a besoin de se
poser des idées neuves et que des
politiques qui répètent sans cesse les
mêmes slogans n'importe pas d'idées
neuves oui je pense qu'il y a besoin
d'une relève il y a besoin d'une
nouvelle génération
je pense que par exemple
le protectionnisme européen j'en parlais
il y a trois ans j'ai pas changé d'avis
la question de l'assistana j'en parlais
il y a quatre ou cinq ans je n'ai pas
changé d'avis les classes moyennes
sujets que j'avais mis sur la table il y
a 5 ans dans lequel à l'époque j'avais
aussi été très critiqué par les mêmes
aujourd'hui je constate que ça devient
un thème qui s'est imposé dans l'opinion
publique finalement on a l'impression
que l'UMP fait du clivage pur et dur
c'est à dire il s'oppose au projet du
gouvernement pour s'opposer alors que
Jean-François Copé lui-même voulait la
suppression des départements quel est
votre position à vous est-ce qu'il faut
te remettre tout à plat concernant le
millefeuille territorial est-ce qu'il
faut supprimer les départements est-ce
qu'il faut réunir les régions parce que
la modernité c'est de soutenir le projet
du gouvernement il y a un point qui me
gêne dans tout ce débat c'est qu'il y a
quelqu'un qu'on oublie c'est l'état
quand on parle de tout ça on ne parle
que de décentralisation on donne au fond
le sentiment que la décentralisation en
soit est bonne et que confier plus de
pouvoir sans cesse à des départements ou
à des régions serait une bonne chose
parce que un on cherche à faire des
économies et puis deux il y a quand même
une dispersion des pouvoirs locaux
est-ce que ça fait des économies non les
régions
a priori oui non les régions
considérablement augmenté la dépense
locale si vous allez dans les hôtels de
Région vous allez tout de suite
comprendre que ça fait pas d'économie si
vous voyez la réalité des dépenses
locales dans les collectivités
régionales vous allez tout de suite
comprendre que ça ne fait pas d'économie
à avoir différentes strates des maires
des intercommunalités des départements
des régions j'aimerais bien qu'on se
pose comme question c'est quels sont les
fonctions qui méritent d'être
décentralisées quelles sont celles qui
mériteraient d'être à nouveau exercée
par l'État pour moi par exemple la
politique en faveur des personnes âgées
c'est une erreur de la confié à des
collectivités locales parce que ça
aboutit à des collectivités locales très
différentes certaines sont riches
peuvent faire beaucoup de choses
d'autres sont pauvres ne peuvent pas
s'occuper de leur personne âgées de la
même manière de vrais engagements
nationaux alors exactement politique
nationale et ceux qui me gêne là
idem pour le RSA ce qui me gêne là c'est
qu'on est dans une espèce de fuite en
avant ou semblent acquis que quoi qu'il
arrive il faille plus de
décentralisation et bien donc il y a
certains moments où il faut à mon avis
remède de la solidarité nationale et ce
que j'aimerais l'occasion de ce débat
c'est que ça ne se réduise pas la
question de savoir est-ce qu'on supprime
le département ou les régions et qu'on
se pose la question de savoir tel
politique qui doit l'exercer la
politique en faveur des personnes âgées
pour moi c'est une politique
gouvernement
et ce qui m'intéresse c'est de savoir
celle là est-ce que oui ou non c'est une
politique de solidarité nationale pour
moi c'est une politique de solidarité
nationale mais est-ce qu'on touche à
quelque chose dans l'organisation du
millefeuille territorial mais bien sûr
c'est je suis maire de ma commune la
première chose que j'ai faite c'est de
rapprocher les services de toutes les
communes pour essayer d'éviter que on
est du millefeuille donc je n'ai aucun
problème là-dessus ça ne choque pas une
demi seconde je voulais
juste qu'il y a eu qui sont venus de
vacances
en politique est-ce que ça vous a touché
est-ce que ça vous a blessé un moment
vous savez c'est jamais agréable et
c'est jamais agréable de voir à quel
point dès que vous essayez de mettre un
débat sur la table et un espèce de
déferlement de politiquement correct et
au fond on a l'impression qu'il y a des
censeurs
politique il n'est pas dans le débat
politique et il a il a une position de
neutralité
il connaît aujourd'hui je
constitutionnel ne doit pas s'exprimer
dans le débat politique et d'ailleurs
Jacques s'est exprimé avec beaucoup de
retenue je m'en explique dans le livre
chaque barreau c'est pour moi un père
spirituel c'est quelqu'un pour qui je
garde une très profonde affection
mais Jacques il défend une Europe qui
est l'Europe que lui a connu cette
Europe là c'est plus celle qu'on a
aujourd'hui l'Europe qu'on a aujourd'hui
elle a trahi l'esprit des pères
fondateurs et je comprends je le dis
d'ailleurs dans livre à quel point ça
peut être douloureux pour des
personnalités des figures comme Jacques
barreau qui ont cru dans cette Europe
qui se sont battus pour aujourd'hui
croire dans l'Europe c'est avoir la
force de dénoncer ces dérives et de
proposer des changements vous êtes
expliqué tous les deux bien sûr c'est
Jacques et quelqu'un pour qui j'ai
énormément d'affection après on peut
avoir des différences sur l'Europe c'est
parfois exprimé avec peut-être un tout
petit peu de violence mais voilà c'est
pas le pour moi je respecte et j'ai une
profonde affection pour lui je ne sors
pas de ça deux questions d'actualité
pour terminer on parlait transparence
tout à l'heure et de déontologie Henri
Guaino qui propose une résolution
Assemblée nationale en sa propre faveur
c'est à dire pour le protéger de
poursuit judiciaire engagée à son
encontre des insultes à magistrats dans
le cas de l'affaire Bettencourt il est
complètement à côté de la plaque Henri
Guaino
faut bien qu'on mette les points sur les
vous connaissez Montesquieu monter ce
qui a posé quoi comme fonctionnement de
base de la démocratie séparation des
pouvoirs et liberté d'expression
fondamentale
puisse s'exprimer et donner son avis sur
le fonctionnement de la justice dans son
pays c'est normal
de sa position députée pour déposer une
proposition de résolution sur son propre
cas l'assemblée est-ce que si vous vous
disiez si vous journaliste vous disiez
les magistrats ont enfin à mon sens les
règles de la démocratie sont allés
au-delà de ce qui devait faire vous
aurez raison c'est votre liberté de
journaliste vous avez votre liberté de
parole et d'expression
de sa liberté d'expression je vais vous
donner un petit scoop si vous étiez
traîné devant la justice parce que vous
auriez critiqué les juges ce serait le
premier à venir vous défendre
comme vous et ça s'appelle la démocratie
il a le droit de s'exprimer comme vous
et un député un parlementaire a le droit
à la liberté d'expression comme un
journaliste une confusion des gens
les conflits d'intérêt là vous n'envoyez
pas non mais pardon il est pas accusé
pour un trafic d'influence il est pas
accusé pour de l'argent il est accusé
pour avoir une parole des injures des
injures c'est à dire il a dit que les
magistrats étaient allés le plus
injures
catastrophiques mais il faut l'Internet
immédiatement rigéno il faut lui mettre
le bâillon sur le sur le visage et une
certaine arrêtons attendez c'est pas
très bien compris l'opinion publique
quand même non je vais vous dire ce qui
n'est à mon avis pas très bien compris
l'opinion publique c'est effectivement
qu'on est le sentiment qu'on ne puissait
mettre aucune critique sur le
fonctionnement de la justice on a le
droit de s'exprimer vous avez le droit
de vous exprimer
et c'est une
vraie avec ces histoires de RAM trop
large dans certains cas de figure tout
le monde demande aujourd'hui la tête des
patrons de la SNCF et réseau ferrée de
France surtout la tête du patron de la
SNCF est-ce que c'est aussi votre cas
parce qu'il faut aller jusque là d'abord
la première chose que je constate c'est
qu'on a totalement perdu le bon sens il
faut quand même que c'est quand même fou
enfin c'est la première chose qui peut
nous choquer pour quelques dizaines de
centimètres on va payer une facture en
dizaine de millions d'euros ce pays est
devenu fou on a vraiment perdu le bon
sens toutes ces normes qu'on a dans tous
les sens sont en train de tuer le pays
la deuxième remarque c'est que je le
trouve quand même que le gouvernement
s'exonère très rapidement de ses
responsabilités et qui a un petit
réflexe de Ponce Pilate voilà un
ministre des Transports à quoi il sert
c'est à dire que au fond
donc il était pas encore
c'est juste un projet structurant et là
ça sort et nous dit il découvre le
problème il dit le système ferroviaire
est gravement défaillant mais il sert à
quoi il est en train de constater que le
système ferroviaire est gravement
défaillant
je pose juste la question il est depuis
2 ans ministre des Transports il a fait
quoi il découvre le dossier deuxième
point Ségolène Royal Ségolène Royal nous
dit il est hors de question que
quelqu'un d'autre que les responsables
payent et c'est vraiment nous prendre
pour des imbéciles qui sont les
responsables ce sont des autorités
publiques sont des épiques qui va payer
à l'arrivée c'est évidemment l'usagée et
le contribuer à c'est lui qui payera et
nous faire croire en disant non non mais
vous inquiétez pas c'est les autres qui
payeront c'est une vaste supercherie
donc je trouve quand même que sur ce
dossier il y a à mon sens une grande
fatigue facilité du gouvernement qui le
plus vite possible c'est déchargé de sa
responsabilité moi je pose la question
simplement ils sont ministres c'est dans
leur portefeuille de responsabilité
quand il fait c'est tout et bien la
question est lancée merci beaucoup
Laurent Wauquiez
je vous retrouve dimanche pour la soirée
spéciale sur Public Sénat la Chaîne
Parlementaire Assemblée nationale bien
sûr pour la soirée des résultats de
l'élection européenne et avec vous même
Perrine puisque vous serez avec le Front
national ce qui va nous occuper mais je
pense une bonne la sortie de la soirée
merci encore Laurent bottier à très vite